let's start with the second part of the
this morning's tutorial my name is Adam
Smith so I'll be picking up where where
Aaron left off and I'll be repeating
just at this for the first few minutes
I'll kind of recap where we were just to
make sure everybody's on the same page
and also because my notation is like a
little different from Aaron's and the
slides so make sure everybody can follow
but basically in some sense what the the
theme of this part of the tutorial is
going to be is it's about the benefits
of hiding the data from the analyst in
various ways and I'll talk about sort of
three related notions of what what we
can mean by it by hiding the data I'll
talk about differential privacy sort of
more slightly more general notions of
algorithmic stability and then various
kinds of information bounds what all
three of these notions allow us to do is
to is to relate some sort of this
adaptive setting that Aaron was talking
about in which you've got an analyst
asking questions in sequence and asking
those questions and have trying to ant
have those answered on the same data set
to some sort of statistical ideal in
which each time I ask a question the
question will be answered using a fresh
sample from the same distribution and in
some sense the these these three these
three tools get a different ways of kind
of matching these two settings and and
relating them so that we can get the
kinds of guarantees we want the kinds of
guarantees we would get in this kind of
statistical ideal setting in this
adaptive setting and as Aaron mentioned
at the end of his tutorial are the the
larger goal here is to develop some sort
of a not only a descriptive theory of
understanding you know when do we over
fit when do we not
but also some sort of prescriptive
theory that tells us how gives us you
know ways to design algorithms and
estimation procedures and analysis
analysis workflows that maximize this or
long-term analytic and statistical value
of the data set data sets we have okay
so I will as with as as Aaron did I'll
spend a lot of time talking about this
this problem of adaptive linear queries
or adaptive statistical queries both
because it's an important problem on its
own but also because it's kind of simple
and clean enough that it's a good
playground for understanding the tools
we have and even though in the
literature that I'll be mentioning
there's lots of other models that people
have looked at I'll just stick to this
because it's it'll keep keep the
discussion more focused so imagine we've
got this again an analyst outside so so
we've got a data set X that is drawn
from some unknown probability
distribution we've got an analyst asking
questions and some algorithm a that is
trying to help the analyst answer these
questions and it's useful to kind of
think of the this process that's
answering the questions is separate from
the analyst even though in reality
they're really the same often the same
person not always okay so what's a query
here it's a it's a function from some
from some domain x201 and there are sort
of several relevant quantities given
this data set X in this distribution P
that were several quantities that we're
going to try to relate to one another
there's the empirical answer so that's
just the average of this query over the
data set there's the population answer
so this is the expectation of the query
on a fresh sample from the same
probability distribution or if we think
of the the population is you know just
an actual population of people then this
would be the average over the population
as opposed to over the sample I have
again I'll sometimes call this empirical
answer the sample answer this population
answer at distribute
answer and we'll say that this the this
algorithm provides answers with error
alpha if for every error for every query
the the answer provided is within alpha
of the actual population mean with some
high probability and I'm gonna sweep
almost all of the high probability stuff
into the O tilde notation okay so you
know these these types of queries
capture lots of basic analyses you know
if you think about a contingency tables
for examples or marginal distributions
they can be represented as a sequence of
such queries classification error of a
candidate classifier certainly fits the
fits this kind of model and also a lot
of more sophisticated optimization
algorithms for example gradient descent
can be thought of as a an adaptive Li
chosen sequence of queries to the
queries of this form and in fact there's
there's a number of recent papers I
think John du chí will talk about one of
them on trying to understand just to
what extent often my adoptive 'ti is
actually necessary in these types of
algorithms I don't know if that's what
you're actually going to talk about good
ok so one question we can answer answer
that or ask that will kind of propel the
propel us forward and sort of trying to
understand the tools we what the tools
we have give us is to aim for a kind of
a minimax theory of this this setting to
try and understand just how small we can
get alpha for a given probability of
success and to understand both upper and
lower bounds on on the error that one
can get in these types of settings so
again what we want as Erin said I don't
have all the quantifiers here but what
we want is to understand the worst case
over distributions and analysts of the
the accuracy of the algorithm where the
algorithm gets a you know a sample from
the distribution so as Erin mentioned if
we if we're asking non adaptive queries
if we just sort of have if the analyst
is not ax
looking at the answers AI but to come up
with subsequent queries then we get a
very clean bound we get this sort of one
over essentially one over square root of
n type behavior and there's some mild
dependency on the number of queries on
the other hand what Aaron convinced us
is that if if if we're answering queries
in the most in the in the simplest and
most direct way which is to just give
answer via the empirical answer on the
data set then what we get is something
more like square root of K over square
root of N and in fact we'd get this
similar scaling or essentially the same
scaling if we were to approach things a
little differently to just chop the data
set into K pieces of the same size and
answer each query on a fresh chunk of
the data set so that would certainly
give us nice analytic guarantees but the
chunks that start to get small once K
gets big okay so what can we do in you
know is there anything we can do in
between so Aaron started to provide
answers to this
in fact okay so in this sort of a
sequence of three papers by the same
authors Cinthia Cinthia dwarf vitaly
Feldman Mart's hearthstone e Passat Tony
Potosi Aaron Roth and and OMA Rheingold
or maybe OMA wrangled and Aaron Roth
that appeared in 2015 they gave a lot of
this tutorial is based on those papers
and they gave you know one bound which
is of this form there is a lower bound
which is sort of incorporates these
these same terms but shows us that a
polynomial dependency on K is in fact
necessary and so that's a really nice
work by well it started with a paper of
Hardin Ullman this bound the specific
bound comes from a subset follow up
papers Duncan Ullman and and then
refining the techniques in this paper of
dork at all right bacilli and
and others including myself gave an
improved bound of about fourth root of K
over N and in fact there remains a gap
in our understanding of the exact the
exact error that we can achieve here
although there are good reasons to think
the right answer is this this fourth
root of K over N so these are these are
kind of bounce on the accuracy it's a
little easy to come easier to compare
them if we say fix alpha and say what's
ask what's the sample complexity that we
need to achieve these bounds and then we
still get this sort of square root of
care everywhere but then it's sort of
more easy to understand the progression
that's going on in these various results
which is really it all comes down to
this dependency on alpha on how accuracy
how accurate we want the queries to be
and the what what basically what we get
is that is that the the kind of current
under open question is exactly what
exponent do we need how does the sample
complexity scale with the with the
accuracy we want but what we do
understand very clearly at this point is
that we really need to pay a significant
cost in the worst case for asking lots
of queries the square root of K term is
known to be necessary so that's just a
quick overview of the of the known
bounds and and now what I'll try to do
is give you a taste of both the tools
that go into these bounds and and also
subsequent developments okay so the
first part of the talk real part of the
talk will be called privacy stability
and generalization pick any three and I
will explain what I mean by that
but roughly speaking what we'll see is
that as Erin mentioned towards the end
of the talk of history took part of the
territorial stable algorithms don't over
fit and we'll think about how to use
that idea okay so one of the key tools
that we'll will start will be thinking
about is differential privacy so I'll
repeat the definition from Aaron's talk
so imagine we've got a data set it's a
set of values in some domains or a
that should be annex this domain could
be numbers or categories or
anything could be arbitrarily
complicated but for the purpose of the
definition we'll think of the data set
as as fixed so it'll be worst case over
data sets and then we'll think of the
the process that analyzes the data is
randomized and our guarantees on
information and stability and things
like that
are going to come from the randomization
that this algorithm does so we'll
consider a thought experiment where we
imagine changing one person's date or
want it that they don't have to be
people one of the data points in in the
data set and well the question we're
going to ask is sort of how sensitive is
this process this algorithm that's
answering questions to changes in the
data and specifically what we want to
know is sort of not so much these aren't
so much questions of numerical stability
of like how much does the answer change
as a number but rather how much does the
distribution how does the distribution
on on outputs change okay so a little
more formally we'll say that data sets X
and X prime are neighbors if they differ
in exactly this one data point and the
requirement our definition will require
that neighboring data sets induce close
distributions on the outputs so
specifically the an algorithm a is
epsilon delta differentially private for
all neighbors X next prime and for all
possible subsets of events all right
sorry for all events in the output space
for all subsets of outputs let's say
there's some these subsets have to be
measurable but we're gonna ignore that
the probability that the output lands in
a given subset when the data set is X
should be close to the probably it lands
in that subset when the data set is x
prime where closeness is measured by two
parameters a multiplicative parameter
which will which can in general be
reasonably large like say 1 over square
root of N or something like that and
additive parameter Delta which which
will generally be very small much
smaller so this is the definition we're
going to work work with and we'll sort
of see various statements about it but
the the right way to think about it in
the context of this tutorial is as a
special case of a very general notion of
algorithmic stability okay so given some
way of measuring how different to
probability distributions are we can say
and we can say that an algorithm is is
stable with respect to that way of
measuring distance or divergence between
distributions if for all data sets if if
I change one entry of the data set the
in do that the change in the induced
distributions on outputs is at most this
parameter row it as measured by that
divergence okay so it's is row stable
with respect to a particular measure of
change if we if the distance between
these two distributions is at most Rho
here D could be something like coal
block Leibler divergence it could be
chi-square divergence a squared distance
it could be a Rennie divergence or a
number of other things and I won't get
into too much of the sort of various
notions of stability that people have
used but I'll try to point them out as
they go but sort of when you get
certainly when you get down into the
into the technical details and certainly
when you're working out concrete bounds
of the form John was asking about
earlier then all these different notions
of divergence really start to matter
so why do we why do we consider
distributional stability why is that
like a useful concept in this quest in
this context well as we say we want to
understand we want to kind of control
what's going on when there's an analyst
asking questions and we have no idea
what's going on analysts head so they're
really two key properties we're going to
use heavily about distributional
stability at least when the this notion
of distance or divergence is chosen
correctly one is that it's generally
closed under further processing
if I buy by other functions and in
particular by the analyst okay so if
we've got an algorithm a which is stable
according to some notion of the form I
had on the previous slide
then it's usually possible to prove that
the output of an analyst who sees the
output of a also satisfies the same
stability guarantee or possibly stronger
so for example for in particular for
differential privacy if a is epsilon
delta differentially private than so is
the composed box beat
and the other the other point that that
Aaron mentioned is that these notions of
distributional stability tend to D
create degrade gracefully when
algorithms are composed in sequence okay
so for example if each if I've got a
sequence if I've got an analyst that is
calling a sequence of adaptively chosen
algorithm so at each stage the analyst
chooses the algorithm that'll be run
then sees its output then chooses the
next algorithm to run and so forth if
each of the algorithms that the analyst
chooses is epsilon-delta differentially
private sorry just ignore the eyes just
imagine they all satisfy the same
guarantee then roughly speaking this
coal box this whole entire process which
outputs the the conversation between the
analyst and these algorithms is going to
be about epsilon square root of K
differentially private okay and other
notions of stability with other notions
of divergence will will yield similar
statements and often the usefulness of a
particular stability notion when you're
proving a particular theorem is going to
come from exactly what kind of
composition guarantee it provides so I
won't I won't list them all but that's
just something to look out for it when
you're reading these papers and it'll
come up I think for example in Vitali
Feldman's talk okay so let's just look
at an example of something that is
differentially private just to make
everything very concrete suppose we've
got some summary function
summary of our data set we want to
release perhaps the answer to a
statistical query but it can live in
some in higher dimension for example I
don't know maybe the proportion of
diabetics and the data set so now each
person's data is just a bit and the
function we're interested in is the
average a simple one simple way to
introduce randomness to the process is
to add noise the value as a function
question is how much noise do we
actually need it turns out that a good
way to think about it is to to kind of
measure some sort of Lipchitz cost
coefficient of the function we're
interested in releasing specifically we
can talk we can ask for the global
sensitivity of the
which is the maximum over neighboring
pairs of datasets in the difference
between f of X and f of X prime is
measured by some appropriate norm on the
outputs l1 norm works well okay so it's
a measure of how sensitive F itself is
to changes in its in its input and for
for the proportion of diabetics or
indeed any statistical query the the
sensitivity is 1 over n because if I
change one of the terms and the sum that
some changes by one the average changes
by one over
okay so it turns out that this global
sensitivity is indeed kind of the right
measure of how much noise we need at
least in general so if we add if we take
our compute f of X and add Laplace noise
proportional to the global sensitivity
over epsilon in each of the components
of the thing we're trying to release
then we indeed get an algorithm which is
epsilon zero differentially private we
don't even need the Delta parameter okay
what's this Laplace distribution well
it's kind of like a Gaussian
distribution but it's a little pointy
err the peak and the tail goes down a
little less heavily and just you know
proof by picture the reason that this
thing is differentially private is what
we're doing when we change one data
point in the data set what we're
considering are two versions of this
laplace density function that have been
shifted relative to one another by the
global sensitivity or maybe with a
global sensitivity over over epsilon and
it turns out that you know point four
point the ratio of the blue and the red
curves is bounded and so we can bound
how much the probability of any event
changes
so this is this is one way to achieve
that satisfy this definition of
differential privacy in fact there's
this there at this point lots of other
algorithmic techniques in addition to
noise addition there's various kinds of
ways to use exponential sampling there a
bunch of other things there's a whole
other class of algorithms based on sort
of local perturbation but but the point
is that if we if we if we develop sort
of general tools and and theorems that
relate properties like differential
privacy to generalization then we get to
use this whole toolbox when we're
designing algorithms and I'll try and
give you some flavor of how that works
so now let me try to formalize this this
idea that that stable algorithms can
over fit and give you a sense of how we
could use that so the final reason that
why we want distributional stability in
addition to kind of composition and
closure and post-processing is that in
some sense distributional stability
gives me protection against overfitting
so consider a game between an analyst
and this algorithm so what the analyst
is going to do is choose a distribution
p on the data and then a dataset will be
sampled which the analyst doesn't see
and hand it to the algorithm and what
the analyst gets is the output of the
algorithm on this freshly sampled random
data set and the analyst will now
produce a statistical query and this the
analysts score in this game is going to
be the difference between the value of
the statistical query on the data set
and the value of the statistical query
averaged over the underlying
distribution so you can think of this as
an overfitting game imagine we've got
this malicious analyst to model you know
the worst possible case who is trying to
come up with like as nasty a query as
possible and sorry of course this is
sort of the same thing as asking the
difference between the value of the
query on this data set in the valley of
the query on a freshly sampled data set
from the same distribution
okay and so what I would say what you
know one of the key insights of this of
the first of these papers by dwarf
Feldman Hart Petoskey often Rheingold de
Bruyn goldenrod sorry it's hard to keep
the are straight is is it connect is
this connection between stability and
and and generalization they proved a
specific one for differential privacy
but they're now subsequently been a
number of results like this that have
been formalized and they have the flavor
that is you know if a is sufficiently
stable with respect to some
appropriately chosen divergence then for
all probability distributions and for
all analysts the the score of the
analyst in this game is somehow bounded
based on how stable the algorithm is and
the measure of divergence we're going to
use
so this is just the same picture as
before
yeah terms of potential privacy but when
you're talking about overfitting and
analysis what should I think
what should I translate might have the
word query so in other words I'm I'm
someone who's trying to come up with a
machine learning model let's say like
the example that Aaron gave and i'm
google I hear I hear Baidu has more
power so the danger is that I I'm trying
to I'm overfitting
so this thing that I'm applying the
hypothesis at right this it's very
confusing to me to use it
some knowledge of query yeah so let's
see so yeah I know you I think you you
you hit on a good point that in some
sense well okay what one of the things
that's going on is that you know we sort
of considered this setting of
statistical queries because it seems
like a it's it's you know for the
reasons I mentioned but well you know
why is that a kind of a reasonable way
to try to capture what's going on in a
lot of statistical analyses so it isn't
always the first answer but one of the
reasons it comes up is a lot of the a
lot of the statistical estimators that
people want to run can be expressed as
in terms of sort of you can rewrite the
algorithm in terms of a sequence of
query you can ask how does the algorithm
that actually computes the estimator
touch the data and very often you can
rewrite the algorithm in terms of a
sequence of quit you can sort of factor
the algorithm out yeah yeah so inside
the algorithm there may be either one or
a sequence of queries so let me give you
just some you know simple examples so
suppose that I'm the Census Bureau and I
am trying to publish a bunch of tables
about you know where people live in the
country that you can think of that as a
large set of statistical queries which
are not really chosen adaptively but
chosen once you know but before the
decennial census is run and then they're
all computed and the sort of algorithm
that the census is running is just going
to compute all those queries find their
answers and publish those values or
perhaps some noisy version of them these
days
on the other hand you can imagine a
single algorithm such as gradient
descent where what's going on is at each
so the algorithm is the algorithm itself
is going to produce proceed in stages
and at each stage of the algorithm it's
going to estimate the gradient of some
loss function on the data and if you
look at what you know what that sort of
computation looks like it's a sum over
data points of each data points
contribution to this gradient and so I
can sort of write the algorithm as
itself like I can sort of refactor the
algorithm if you will in terms of you
know here's the data and here is you
know some process controlling the
algorithm and it's submitting I don't
know points let's call them W and it's
getting back estimates of the gradient
of some the gradient at W of some loss
function defined by the data set
so I'm not sure if I'm providing the the
best answer to your question but so now
I can imagine is like you know gradient
descent is like this whole thing but I
can abstract it out a little bit by
breaking it into two pieces there's this
sort of the control piece that decides
which points to query and then there's
like the point the part that actually
holds the data that answers sometimes
called the Oracle that actually answers
the questions so I hope that was helpful
and yeah yeah well right so applying
this particular framework that I'm
talking about requires sort of thinking
about what in fact the prot the
estimation process you want to use is
doing by the way that the this whole
framework applies also equally well when
I've got many different people using the
same data set which is I think where it
really becomes useful such as the
machine learning competition and there
that sort of factoring in two separate
processes has already provided imagenet
is the algorithm that is answering
queries and the analysts are the people
out there submitting control processes
is the people competing in the
competition who are submitting candidate
classifiers and getting back answers or
if imagine I've got like you know the
add health data set is this like data
set that is used by that's about the big
data set about Adolescent Health one
data set something like 4,000 papers
each of which possibly is the analysis
chosen in paper you know I was chosen
based on reading papers some subset of
papers one through I minus one maybe
going to some talks you know so then
there's all sorts of complex
dependencies you can think of lots of
other examples
okay so just instantiating this theorem
you we get a sequence of lemmas so so
the four differential privacy we get a
statement of the following form if a is
differentially epsilon-delta
differentially private then the score of
the analyst in this game is bounded by
you know ten Epsilon with with very high
probability we can also get and this is
the theorem we're gonna use this theorem
a few times but I just want to mention
there are sort of similar theorems for
other notions of stability for example
if we have stability in the total
variation distance this the usuals -
well what for computer scientists is the
usual statistical difference on
distributions then what we get is sort
of a weaker guarantee what we can prove
is the expected score is going to be
about epsilon or order of Epsilon and I
don't really know where this first
appeared I first heard this from Frank
McSherry but it's sort of a I'll show
you the proof it's it's kind of a
classic thing that predate you goes back
to the 70s in some sense before before
Frank was born yeah so another kind of
one that comes on handy a lot that gives
very clean bounds is if you look at
stability in the cope like leibler
divergence then what you get is a bound
on the root mean score of the analyst in
this game again about epsilon and that
I'm not sure exactly where the first
place that appeared is but you know
roughly it comes from this paper
Rousseau and so I apologize if I'm
screwing up the references and then
there's a version of this that another
thing that comes in handy for concrete
computations but I won't go through is
what's called concentrated differential
privacy or zero concentrated
differential privacy and it gives sort
of essentially the same this type of
statement but with in some cases with
better constants
ok so these are the kinds of statements
that people use and I'm going to prove
one of them I'm going to prove for you
the the second bullet and then I'll just
give you an idea of how you can get use
that to get say prove a statement like
in the first bullet so what's the thing
we want to prove if we've got an
algorithm it's stable in total variation
distance so that means if I change one
input its distribution changes very
little in statistical difference or
total variation then for all
distributions P we get the following if
I choose the data set from P iid and I
look choose the output of a based on X
and I look at the expected difference
between the the the empirical answer and
the population answer then that expected
difference is small
strewth I'm gonna first let's fix the
distribution P without loss of
generality so the analyst chooses that
we'll just condition on P being whatever
it was and we're gonna consider we're
going to compare the two distributions
on two triples of values okay so the
first triple is our data set together
with a random index I so sorry that I
guess that's missing so I'm going to
imagine the first data I've got my data
set X I've got an index I and then I've
got a of X and I'm going to consider an
alternative sort of an alternative
reality in which in the data set I'm now
going to sample so here's here's my
initial data set what I'm going to do is
I'm going to sample fresh value for
position I of the data set and I'm going
to replace that in a Z I'm gonna replace
a's input with instead of giving it X
the real X I'm going to give it almost
the real X but exactly one entry will be
changed okay now what stability in total
variation gives us is that the distance
between these two distributions the
distribution on this triple and the
distribution on this triple where
everything is sampled iid from P that
statistical difference is at most
epsilon not easy it not hard to prove it
basically you're using some convexity of
total variation distance all right so
what why is that a useful thing well
what does total variation distance tell
us it tells you if tells you if you take
any bounded function on a random
variable and then if you change the
random variable in total variation
distance epsilon the expectation of the
bounded function will change by at most
Epsilon that's like a definition of of
total variation distance and so here's
the specific
function we're gonna look at we're gonna
look at taking so this function takes a
xxx I and some value we'll call it y
we'll take the value Y we'll choose a
query based on it according that will
run the analyst so the analyst has been
baked into F at this point and now but
we will evaluate this query at exactly
one point which is the ithe coordinate
of X all right so total variation
distance is about expectations let's
evaluate the expectations in the first
case when I evaluate this expectation
what am I getting I'm I'm running a I'm
picking a random index in X and I'm
evaluating F remember value in queue of
a on that random index in expectation
what I get is the average over X okay so
what I'll get in expectation is exactly
like the first term up here on the other
hand in the second world where I've like
replaced just this one data point then
what's going on is I've I'm computing a
according to the the same distribution I
was computing it before except now I'm
evaluating my query on some sample from
the distribution that a didn't get to
that a never was involved with okay and
so now in expectation again what I'm
gonna get is not not the value on the
data set but the value on the on the on
the underlying in the plot of the
average over the population you know if
if my algorithm didn't satisfy this type
of stability guarantee and its output
like was really sensitive to individual
data points these two distributions
could be wildly different okay but
because we have a stability guarantee we
know that they can't be that different
and so in particular these two
expectations are close they're off by at
most Epsilon
and so by linearity of expectation we
get the line
so this is a very simple proof I think
but it basically gets at why this
stability property is useful now I
cheated actually the dilemma I stated on
the previous slide was actually about
the absolute value of this expectation
the expectation of the absolute value
and what I just bounded was the absolute
value of the expectation say no
attention to the to the absolute value
behind the curtain
but this I think in just conceptually
this is the proof to have in mind
so in fact to get this yeah you need a
little more work to get the absolute
value in the right place but I'm not
going to do that so that gives you some
sort of bound on expectations but in
fact what we want you know bounds on
expectations are very weak we want high
probability bounds on generalization
error and we need them in a number of
applications and it turns out you can
get essentially sub Gaussian style
concentration but then you need more
than just total variation stability you
need to go a little further generally
the best things we have asymptotically
are based on epsilon differential
privacy epsilon Delta differential
privacy and the idea of how these are
obtained is what came to be called the
monitor technique or version one of the
monitor technique and this is due to
Coby and Ori and the idea is I'm gonna
to sort of amplify it to get a high
probability bound I'm gonna I'm gonna
start with an expectation bound and then
like amplify probabilities somehow so
I'm gonna imagine that I've got an
analyst that succeeds with some some
probability Delta and I'm gonna show
that Delta can't really be too big and
the way I'm gonna do that is I'm gonna
consider running 1 over Delta
independent copies of this little
overfitting game and then I'm gonna use
some differentially private algorithm to
select like the worst performance from
the mechanisms point of view or the best
performance from the analysts point of
view and I'm gonna argue that
so now I've got this sort of composed
process where I've got a bunch of
independent copies of this game plus
some monitor on the outside that is
choosing differentially privately
choosing the best the the the
interaction where the analysts got the
highest score and what what what Newsom
and stammers show how to do is to argue
that this composed algorithm first of
all is differentially private so that's
that's easy that you just use the
composition for differential privacy
with and where the the the privacy
guarantee has no dependence
Deonte it just depends on the original
properties of the algorithm and then
there's a sort of a more subtle thing
that they prove which is that they
extend this expectation bound that I had
on the previous slide to show that when
when the algorithm is differentially
private you the algorithm in expectation
should not be able to overfit to any of
these T datasets okay so I'm not gonna
formalize this part at this parts like
this is sort of where the magic happens
and it requires a calculation but like
that's the some sense the crux of the
proof but yeah so this this the idea is
we get sort of high probability bounds
by some kind of amplify contradiction we
assume that there were an analyst that
could exceed the bound of the
probability you know 1% run a hundred
copies of this game and show that
actually if if the if the analysts
concede in each in each execution
probably 1% then overall in the composed
game the analysts who exceed with it
would succeed a lot of the time and
that's the thing that from which we
derive the contradiction
oh so what is this God oh right I wanted
to say one more thing before we wrap up
okay so there's another thing about this
proof that I wanted to point out to you
and this comes from a paper this way of
phrasing it I think it was made to me
you know clear to me in a paper by so
much Joe and Matt Fredrickson and some
others although it probably appears
elsewhere but in some sense what this
tells me is like you know sort of
privacy style properties imply
generalization but in vice-versa
that's almost like a tight
characterization of generalization like
if if I've got something that
generalizes poorly where it's possible
to come up with a query that makes this
difference large then exactly what I've
done is to find is to find a place where
to find an algorithm that somehow paying
attention to individual data points to
and telling me a lot about like one
person in the data set and so these sort
of properties are kind of very very
tightly linked
okay so let's try and use this to do
stuff again here's our here's our
picture from before what we want to do
is understand maybe like this bound and
also I want to connect it to the kinds
of things that Aaron was talking about
the kinds of algorithms based on
compression that Aaron was talking about
in the previous part of the tutorial
okay so to do this what we'll do is
we'll sort of take that that
generalization bound which applied to
just a two stage game like o or a one
you know a game with exactly one kind of
interaction with the analyst and I want
to kind of generalize that two more
interactions so the lemmas we had before
Connect accuracy on the population with
sample accuracy now what I want to do is
get something useful for answering
statistical queries lots of statistical
queries so to formalize it we'll say
that the algorithm a is alpha beta
sample accurate if it's worst case error
if for every particular data set it
might interact with and for every
sequence of queries with high
probability it's giving answers that are
accurate for the data set X means that's
what sample accuracy means and the nice
thing about sample accuracy is that it's
sort of easy to prove because there's
sort of much less probability involved
right there's note that you just got one
data set you write it down it's a
worst-case thing
the sort of general connection between
sample accuracy and privacy is that if
I've got an algorithm as differentially
private and it is alpha beta sample
accurate then indeed the worst case the
worst of the worst general population
error taken over all the queries is
going to be bounded by alpha plus
Epsilon where alpha is the sort of error
on the sample and epsilon is the
stability guarantee it with some
probability okay and there are sort of
similar theorems that are possible for
weaker stability notions although they
they generally give you like you know
weaker or different probability
guarantees so how do we get this and so
intuitively this this sounds like a
direct application of those sort of
previous lemmas but there's actually a
hitch
which is that somehow we what we need is
the we need a good way to handle the
fact that there could be many many
rounds of back and forth conversation
between the analyst and this algorithm
that's providing answers and in some
sense that is going to be that it turns
out that will actually be very simple to
resolve but sort of it's the crux of the
proof at this point so what the lemmas
we had in the the previous slides talked
about was sort of what happens with just
two steps where I asked a query get an
answer ask a second query get an answer
now I want to kind of lift this result
to K steps okay so the simplest way to
do this would be by induction all right
everybody likes induction one thing we
could do is sort of imagine that you
know we're gonna see view this as a
sequence of two stage games and so to
Anders understand how much I can overfit
at the at the I stage I'll just think of
the algorithm that processes the first I
minus one queries is one big chunk it
gives some output the analyst chooses
the I've query and you know you can
bound how much the analyst overfits
and then what you can do is basically
just take a Union bound over all these
different rounds and if you just add up
the probability of getting a bad query
each round then you'll get you'll get a
final bound on the the probability that
you ask a bad query at any time but the
problem is that then you get this
dependency on K this linear dependency
on K in the probability of getting a bad
query and so it turns out there's sort
of a second way to use this sort of
outside monitor idea which works very
well here which is instead of trying to
analyze things as a sequence of
interactions we'll just look at one big
look at the whole interaction as one big
piece and we'll imagine an algorithm and
a sort of a meta algorithm that includes
an that sort of runs the analyst runs
this insert or interaction and knows the
distribution P and what this sort of
monitor algorithm will do is at the end
of the interaction they'll take the
worst of all the queries that was asked
and it will return just that query as
its output so this is sort of a kind of
like that high probability argument but
different because now I've just got one
data set and so now what we can do is
now we can just say like well how does
this algorithm do it overfitting okay
and because we know that this algorithm
over fits you know won't over fit in
either like an expectation or in with
high probability then what we that tells
us about the kind of the worst
interaction that occur that could have
occurred over the entire sequence and in
terms of so this this yields much
stronger bounds on on you know the error
and another nice thing that I'm not
really going to go into is that it
generalizes beyond these linear queries
this type of argumentation gives them
more and also it gives you it it means
when you're working with weaker
stability notions like KL stability
often this is a big different this makes
a huge difference in the
results you can get so let's let's use
these sort of tools we've developed for
this transfer theorem okay so one
question is you know what happens with
worst waste cure weight worst case
adaptively posed its statistical queries
well the thing we're going to use is
that so the thing we want to prove is
that one can answer an arbitrary
sequence of K adaptively chosen
statistical queries with error as I said
fourth root of K over square root of n
okay or in terms of sample complexity
square root of K over alpha squared and
the algorithm is just is very simple on
each query it's just going to add a
little bit of noise to the output and
return the noisy answer to the analyst
okay so it's in some sense the analyst
is for themselves adding noise to their
queries and it turns out that sorry so
what we're going to do to prove the the
thing we want we're just going to try
and analyze well how well does this do
in terms of differential privacy and how
well does it do in terms of sample
accuracy then we can use that transfer
theorem to put the pieces together
okay so so the dilemma is that if we add
Laplace noise about epsilon over square
root of K to each of a sequence of K
statistical queries then and get in
indeed we get sample accuracy on the
order of about square root of K over
epsilon n okay so that just follows by
the composition lemma that we had in the
previous that had number of slides back
so this algorithm is you know epsilon
prime I'm adding no a parameter I've got
parameter epsilon Prime at each step and
the epsilon Prime's add up in sort of
the square what I get the final
guarantee I get is like square root of K
times epsilon prime which is epsilon so
that's what I want and the the sample
accuracy I get is about square root of K
over epsilon n plus some other stuff and
now if I just apply that transfer
theorem what I get is that the the
worst-case population accuracy that this
process will give me is square root of K
over epsilon n plus the epsilon that I
lose when I'm translating from sample
accuracy to population actors and now
all I do is I pick the right epsilon to
minimize the the sum and then what I get
is the square root of square root of K
over N which is fourth root of K over
square
so again you know at a high level what's
going on I'm just taking some well
understood process whose stability
guarantees are easy to analyze and whose
sample accuracy is really easy to
analyze and I'm sort of getting out of
this hold machinery for free or at a
cost of epsilon I'm getting a guarantee
on the population accuracy on how much I
could over fit
and relative to say sample splitting
which we talked about a long time ago or
just providing the straight empirical
answer the the big win is I've bought
myself an extra square root in the
dependency on K so I went from square
root of K over square root of n to
fourth root of K over square root of n
which is a you know a significant
improvement when I've got lots and lots
of queries and it turns out that sort of
quadratic improvement that comes up over
and over again in the applications of
these types of results yeah John just to
help me contextualize things so if we
were to use like a zero concentrated
differential privacy type of thing do
these arguments simplified because we
now we no longer need to track around
these sort of 1 on Delta things yeah you
get much cleaner statements yeah just
use those for these kinds of results the
short answer is no the sort of longer
answer is in a tutorial that requires
like more definitions so that is the the
reason I did not do that but yeah so
actually ohm Thakur is like not in the
room right now but as a student at BU
will hopefully give a talk on some sort
of more experimental stuff we're doing
with with aaron and ryan rogers trying
to track like how do you get the best
concrete bounds out of this process and
generally what you the best bounds are
you gonna get are like mix and match and
mixing and matching these are various
notions of stability and these argument
in a few different ways do we have any
say hope of some kind of asymptotic
argument giving exact constants
not currently so right now we have in
some regimes matching asymptotic upper
and lower bounds but the there are
numerical constants actually no there
like to with if you try to optimize
everything they're not that big but that
doesn't yeah we don't really understand
when they're baked a times they're like
two and sometimes they're like 50 and
understanding yeah two and fifty are
indeed different all right so just just
quickly Aaron mentioned this sort of
reusable holdout idea he said we could
answer K queries where they're nearly
independent of K by using this dirty set
to generate guesses and some clean like
holdout holdout to verify guesses and
when appropriate set them straight okay
and there's this really elegant
compression argument that says in some
sense the cost I pay in terms of
accuracy is going to scale not with the
number of not exactly only logarithmic
ly with the total number of queries I
have to answer but that sort of the
polynomial cost is only going to come in
the number of queries where my guesses
are wrong it's the wrong guesses that
are surprising that reveal information
about the clean set so now what we could
do is come up with a version of that
where we use like instead of using the
compression argument we use these
stability arguments and what we get out
of it is instead of we get basically a
quadratic improvement in the dependency
on n so instead of the kind of error
being whatever that threshold was plus
this square root of W log K over N that
Aaron mentioned and I'm dropping even
more terms than he had dropped this and
my clogged stuff then what we obtain is
sort of this sort of same numerator but
with like n in the denominator instead
of square root of N and so I just want
to explain a little bit about how that
works but anyway the point is that that
you know this parent guarantees better
than that right
that's all you really need to remember
but what how does this work well what we
need is sort of a stability based
version of that art that compression
argument that said only the wrong
answers really matter so the this thing
has a name it's called the sparse vector
mechanism it comes from a paper
originally a paper of Aaron and Tim ruff
gardens and also maybe was sort of
worked out in modern form by Moore it's
heart and guy Roth bloom suppose we have
a sequence of statistical queries and
East each asks for the average of some
bounded function over the data posted
actively same thing set up as before and
now we just want to know rather than
knowing the values of all the queries we
just want to know those values that
exceed a certain threshold okay so in
application this what I'm actually going
to be apply it to is like the difference
between a guess and and the true value
but like that doesn't really matter okay
just imagine I've got a threshold each
of the queries I want to compare to that
threshold and I'm going to sort of say
nope and wait I forget which one was yes
and which one was no I'll say one thing
if they're above threshold and another
thing if they're below threshold and
it's the above threshold ones that are
surprising was that yep or nope great
but is yes above or a sniffle okay good
thank you
okay so here's here's the mechanism so
actually I'm cheating I'm cheating a
little bit I've simplified it to the
point of being technically not correct
but like morally correct so this is the
morally correct version of sparse vector
I've got I've got a data set X and this
sort of sequence of queries coming along
and now what I'll do is I'll just sort
of track how many times I've raised my
flag and said oh you're above threshold
and as long as I haven't raised it W
times I keep going and basically for
each query I'm going to add what I'm
gonna do is add noise to the
a query answer on the on my data
I mean oiss of that and I'm gonna
compare that to the threshold okay so
what I'm doing is just a noisy version
of that threshold check that was in the
the the guess and check thing that that
Aaron described and effectively what
this says is like if I'm far from the
threshold I'm Garrett essentially
guaranteed to do the right thing if you
ask me a query that's right near the
threshold maybe I'll give you the right
answer maybe I won't you don't and if I
am whenever I am above threshold I you
know raise a flag with my hand and the
flag counter goes up and otherwise I
just keep going okay and again the
theorem which applies to the correct
version of this not exactly to this is
that if I set epsilon prime to be about
epsilon over the square root of the
number of bad things that can happen
right W then I get an algorithm which is
overall differentially private and it is
correct with high probability for all
those queries that are not super close
to the threshold okay so now I have this
additional source of error which is like
the corresponds this is the sample error
in the in the in the transfer theorem so
this is going to be you know some source
of error mean which is where the things
go wrong okay I'm going to sort of skip
over the sorry I'm running out of time
so I'm not going to go over it too much
but okay so for the compression analysis
Oh for the median mechanism that Aaron
mentioned you can sort of dude saying
I'm not gonna work through it you can
st. use same ideas you go from like some
dependency on you know one over fourth
root of n down to one over square root
of n if you use these different tools
for the ladder algorithm and this was
worked out in a paper more it's called
climbing a shaky ladder if I have the
right title right
I have it in terms of sample complexity
here because I think it's it's sort of
easier to see what's going on here
you're going from a dent dependency on
alpha cubed down to a dependency of like
you're buying yourself a square root of
alpha in the accuracy guarantee and sort
of similarly a lot of these places where
compression algorithms are this
compression based analysis can be used
such an another album called
multiplicative weights you get a kind of
a corresponding improvement so what I
can try to convince you of is it's for
privacy and stability are sort of
intimately collected with generalization
we can use that in various interesting
ways and in the - well we started late
but those like minute I have left I want
to just convince you that there's also a
connection to information theory and I'm
gonna kind of punt two other talks to
make this connection more explicit
hopefully vitaly Feldman and Max
Baginski will will say more but let me
just sort of sketch that connection okay
so again here's our Arthus our little
two stage game where the analyst sees
one answer from one output from an
algorithm and produces a query and now
we want to analyze this game but using a
different sort of way of that rather
than thinking about stability using like
a different kind of mental model and the
thing we're going to do is to try and
explicitly measure in from the
information in the output that is that
the output conveys about the input data
set okay when the input data set is
chosen iid according to P some another
distribution
okay so there are lots of ways to
measure information you've probably
heard of Shannon's notion of mutual
information so that's looks at the
expectation of this log odds ratio where
you're looking at the probability that
the output would be Y conditioned on a
particular data set X compared to the
probability that the output would be y
conditioned on nothing averaged over all
data sets X that's like a well may you
know you may have heard that's usually
called mutual information and there are
other variations on this there's
something called UMAX information which
is a high probability bound on this
ratio there are various other notions
like you could look at some you know
expectation over Y over the supremum
over X of this ratio and various other
things you can look at moments of the
ratio those are called rennie
divergences or any measures or any
information and so what we can get is
based on a variety of these measures of
information we can get different kinds
of guarantees on again how well the
analysts can do in this game so just the
way almost all of these play out is that
what we find out is that the score of
the analyst to me this game is bounded
roughly speaking by the the square root
of the information that's leaked over N
and if and and then okay so the first
theorem I know that was like well I
guess this sort of appeared 22 papers in
2015 there's one of the dork adult
papers and also Rousseau and so that
proved statements along of this flavor
and these things come can we can connect
them to this sort of stability based
approach and also compression if we can
connect stability to information indeed
you can so for example if an algorithm
is epsilon-delta differentially private
then the some approximate version of the
max information is bounded by about
epsilon squared over N
and if an algorithm is compressible if
it's output is compressible 2l bits then
the somehow L got changed into K then
the max information is bounded by L and
if I just sort of plug these two
theorems into this metal I'm I get again
those two types of statements I had
earlier and like everything works out
like if I plug epsilon squared in
epsilon squared n into this statement I
get that the score is bounded by epsilon
which is exactly what we had before so
we can reinterpret a number of these
stability based guarantees in terms of
information and that gives us extra
flexibility when designing algorithms
and they're sort of ways this comes up
that I'm not going to go into but I want
to give you one's very specific
connection which is with hypothesis
testing and I want to kind of go through
this because it's relevant to the types
of questions that get asked in many of
the papers on selective inference in the
statistical literature
okay so let's consider promises my last
technical slide let's consider an an
analyst that instead of choosing a weird
statistical query is choosing a
hypothesis test okay so the that you can
an analyst sees the output of some
process based on the data set and now
formulates a conjecture about the
probability distribution that might have
generated that data and that conjecture
will look like will be a set of like
it'll be a predicate on on the
distribution P so a set of possible
distributions and then a sort of normal
way we analyze this and say well we'll
look at that what's called a
significance level of the test so this
is the probability that my test rejects
so it'll choose a so that sorry the
analyst chooses a statistical test so
that's just like a binary function on
the binary valued function on data and
normally the thing will be concerned
with is the probably that the test would
output one which is called rejecting
given that the hypothesis actually
satisfied the conjecture and that the
data set were selected according to the
hypothesis fresh data set was selected
according to my box so there's some sort
of soup over P hiding in here okay and
so let's call that p0 so let's say I've
got an analyst which will always choose
a test and a hypothesis whose level of
significance is p0 so then you know 5%
if you're submitting a paper to nature
what can we do well one simple thing is
to look at them you can get other
formulations of the statement but this
one you can prove like on a napkin so
it's like easy so suppose I had a
guarantee about the max information
between the algorithm a and the data set
X then I could actually use it to sort
of bound how bad the kind of possibility
of a false acceptance is even when this
this conjecture was formulated
adaptively based on the output of the
algorithm and specifically what we can
say is that if the mutual information is
that Moceri if the max information isn't
most K then when i additionally
conditioned on the fact that the test
was chosen as part of the output of a
the test and h0 were chosen as part of
based on the output of a then this
probability of bad stuff happening goes
up by a factor of at most 2 to the K and
the proof of this is like two lines it
basically just based on this is the fact
that this odd ratio is at most 2 to the
K there's a log missing I'm sorry I lost
a log there should be a log
okay so what does this tell us it tells
us that at least max information and
there are similar versions for other
notions of information you can think of
it as a measure of like how distorted
the conditional distribution on X is by
the fact that you've revealed this
output a and because you know that it
wasn't distorted too much I mean
couldn't distort it a lot effect or to
the K if K is big you know it's a big
factor but it's finite and it's
something you can write down for can you
compute K I mean for various algorithms
we can prove stuff about K yeah we can
prove bounds on K so in particular okay
maybe I won't go into that but for
example for these these algorithms that
are compressible that Aaron mentioned or
algorithms that satisfy various
stability notions you can definitely
prove mutual information bounds and
other types of information bounds and in
fact there's a few recent papers and I
don't want to say too author names
because I'll get them wrong that make
sort of look at other types of
algorithms whose information leakage can
be bounded learning like say it learning
in statistical algorithms
but basically what information this sort
of these notions of information very
explicitly connect the sort of stability
type perspective with the kind of
conditional inference perspective that
comes up a lot in the stats literature
ok so that's what I talked about you
know we concluded adaptive inferences
everywhere there's a you know great
quote all inference is selective I
forget who I shouldn't tribute that to
but it's certainly true they're just
it's it's hard to find settings where
you're not making conjectures based on
things you've noticed about the data for
example we can get non-trivial results
for arbitrary analyst behavior using
these notions of stability and
information and one thing to point out
is that these give us in addition these
give us sort of two-sided guarantees in
addition to sort of allowing us to write
out you know algorithms that that
guarantee a certain levels statistical
validity you can guarantee ahead of time
that you're going to be able to provide
answers of a given accuracy so it's not
only ex post facto that you can figure
out how well you did you can actually
you know think about you think it
through ahead of time which is a useful
thing I I didn't talk about lower bounds
but there are sort of various regimes in
which these results are tight some
others in which they're not an
information instability play key roles
limitations that current theory it's
most useful when you've got lots and
lots of rounds of interaction where as
you know a number of lots of natural
statistical settings you have maybe two
right and and then the last thing I want
to say there's sort of tons of stuff I
didn't talk about that you know a
tutorial could have covered I didn't
talk about lower bounds on accuracy and
the sort of exact regimes in which we
know they work and they don't I didn't
talk about how you get concrete bounds
out of any of this stuff everything had
Tilda's everywhere and hand-waving
i didn't talk about sort of works that
have and there are a few now that have
started to think about accuracy sort of
as a good set you know data as a public
and sort of how do you suppose I've got
it I'm the NIH I pay for an expensive
study I collect a bunch of data how do I
help how do I decide like who gets to
ask queries who doesn't and like how I
ration out the kind of value of that
data right
Blake we'll talk a little bit about that
I didn't talk about models of more
benign adversarial behavior I'll talk a
little bit about that tomorrow
and I barely scratch the surface talking
about adaptive hypothesis testing
there's much more to say there so with
that with this sort of caveat on all the
and there probably others but a bunch of
things I didn't talk about I will stop
thank you so I'm happy to take questions
yeah well sorry yeah okay in that case
well I'm